i [ __ ] them all soder big j shane
gillis
[Music]
uh i'm josh adam myers and i'm here to
answer the internet if you could have an
endless supply of anything
what would it be if i was still a drug
addict i would say uh percocet 30
milligrams they are
they are the greatest thing in the world
the [ __ ] you'll do for them is so bad so
if i just had them non-stop
that's the end you're
you wouldn't have to hurt anybody
it would be great if you had to have a
threesome with one male actor who would
it be i don't know why bob de niro
popped in my head it was like him or
pesci dude that would be so cool does
the [ __ ]
just those three just three you're
patchy deniro
oh yeah yeah yeah there's two more wait
we're [ __ ] each other
i'd [ __ ] peschy
why not
dude it's a conversation starter at like
a dinner party it's like well you know i
[ __ ] joe pesci
you would spotty and i'll say this i
this girl i used to whose apartment i
rented when i first moved to new york uh
she's kind of a socialite she's friends
with all of us in the comedy world uh
she's only [ __ ] three people in her
life one of them is robert de niro i
swear to god i swear to god you have an
ati question it's uh would you rather be
able to i think it's always drink
without getting a hangover
uh pull it in pull any girl you want
like any girl at the bar she'll go home
with you or you get to be best friends
with joe pesci
so i can either
drink never get a hangover [ __ ] that
pull any girl
at the bar that i've ever wanted or [ __ ]
joe
is don't pesci be best friends with them
you don't be best yeah well i mean
that's what my friendships are like dude
we [ __ ]
oh we [ __ ]
i [ __ ] them all soder big j
shane gillis it is funny that he thought
it was [ __ ] he was going through it
like all right it's a [ __ ] unlimited
amount of girls or jokes
i mean how can you not say pull any girl
that you've ever wanted to pull i mean
that's cause that's but also that's the
way it should be like i i was thinking
about it's like we should be [ __ ] so
much more than we do we have such a
short time on this earth like there's no
reason that i couldn't just go up to a
girl at chipotle and be like you're
really hot we should uh would you want
to go [ __ ]
i'm not creepy no i'm like i have a job
okay yeah and then we just go so i can
ah so yeah paulie girl but i but like
once again it was really tough to get
not [ __ ] joe pesci
you'd be fun man
would you rather [ __ ] a chick who's
banged a thousand dudes or a chick who's
banged one animal
come on dude
one animal
easily
antibiotics this is a good one for me
would you rather orgasm every time you
hear all star by smash mouth or hear all
star every time you orgasm
dude hearing all-star every time i
orgasm would [ __ ]
rule
dude just you just ha ha hey now
somebody once told you the world
dude 100
there's actually a really great video uh
of uh the lead singer drunk at uh
i think he will i don't want to say the
wedding because it's somebody famous
that hired him but he had like a full
drunk outburst uh but yeah like the
wedding band they hired him he spent
like twenty thousand thirty thousand
dollars for him to come and play like
three songs and instead he just got
tanked and just caused a seat wouldn't
get off the stage
he's cussing like [ __ ] this and you're
like it's a wedding dude what are you
doing it sucks to the person getting
married to everybody else like this is
the greatest wedding i have ever been to
it's like honey i'm saying i'll get him
to stop you turn around your friends
like this [ __ ]
keep going getting more drinks getting
more drinks dude would you guys have me
you guys put music on when you [ __ ] a
sonos used to sponsor my podcast the 500
so i
so i just have like alexa set up so i'm
just like alexa play porter's head or
like massive attack i've started getting
into more 80s so like the cure
cure has been good bauhaus i'm into the
dark [ __ ] dude
really i i'm i'm big into into sex music
it's just not like it's not like
pounding like it's like it's not like i
have like
that
i'm just like doing the beat it's just
it's on
because sex noises [ __ ] suck dude
who
is the worst group of fans
uh
40 year old white women
they're the worst they're ruining comedy
you're gonna grow into one
one day every weird outburst every fan
that i've ever had walk out of a show
has been a white woman in her 40s a
drunk white woman or 40s they're the
worst and it's the ruining comedy if you
watch any comic they will say 40 year
old white drunk woman in order for you
to live you have to kill a blind child
who has the greatest
voice of our generation
are you killing the kid in order for me
to live yeah [ __ ] that kid
[ __ ] that kid
sorry everybody i could sing too
[Music]
i'd be like yeah
oh
see
can you see
we good we're good right [ __ ] that kid
would you rather have no music for the
rest of your life or have all music be
sung by your significant other music is
the most beautiful thing in the world
it's the it's the one thing that it like
dude if that's but that's the other
option is i have nothing nothing i have
no music at all and it's like
i mean the memories it's still like it's
not enough so if it's just like a really
bad rendition of hey jude
i'd take it like i just
it sucks but man
i mean she's trying i don't know like
she's
god we get you into some singing lessons
or something
is eiffel towering a chick with another
guy gay an eiffel tower is like so i'm
behind he's in the front and we just
[ __ ] high five no
it's not gay if we've learned anything
from the tv show euphoria anything goes
now dude anything goes
it's just banging what would you say uh
you know like uh good old-fashioned dp
is two two balls together with a guy
that's probably a little bit uh homo
rock it's definitely homoerotic two two
dicks going into the same hall i think
the only thing that's gay is [ __ ] a
guy
um
i think that's the clinical definition
of gay
it got me there i i think i don't think
threesomes with two guys and a girl is
gay
unless the guys start doing [ __ ] to each
other yeah i don't think
you start sucking the dude's dick that's
gay
that's gay if you start enjoying it
it's gay dude if you're gay if you're
like [ __ ] yeah let me just let me just
flex a little bit to make it stronger so
he feels like i want this guy to feel as
good as i feel right now
you start pushing the blood there even
more
it's gay
but there's nothing wrong with that no
there's nothing wrong with that
everybody
would you rather give up the hungover
breakfast sandwich or the drunk pizza i
would rather give up the drunk pizza
because breakfast is the best meal of
the day i love pizza don't get me wrong
pizza is the [ __ ] [ __ ] everybody but
but i love like a bagel [ __ ] uh
bacon egg and cheese on like a whole
wheat everything is my that's my [ __ ]
jam that's my [ __ ] jam but drunk
pizza is the [ __ ] though dude but also
i'll trade both those for uh for sober
late night high swedish fish
you brought me back in all right
if you were born
this made me laugh already if you were
born with action figure hands stuck in
same position forever what position
would your hands be in it's on here but
[Laughter]
this is just this is great dude
because you can still
kind of you can chop-stick it a little
bit
it's either that take a lobster claw
well what's the other option this well
right now
let me think about it for a second hold
on let me really think about it you're
exclusively thinking about [ __ ] right
now aren't you yeah but i'm also
thinking about like i'm also thinking
about like there was a coffee mug i
could like so i'd want a little bit of a
give in between so really this is kind
of i think this is what i'd want right
here can we see it
with a gap so then i can like hook [ __ ]
yeah
thumbs outside the box here my dick's
not that thick
but i could make that work
i could figure it out maybe like this i
think it would kind of have to be like
this to actually be what about just a
good old fashioned like that
this is so dumb
there you go
but missy there's just it's got to be
just enough space to get [ __ ] through
you rather be a pig and be able to
orgasm for 30 minutes or be a lion and
be able to have sex 60 times a day
that's a good question i would still go
with the lion because just the lion is
like the [ __ ] you know most badass
animal in the animal kingdom
is outside the sex stuff just because
yeah yeah but then but also man you ever
seen what a female lion looks like dude
that's some good [ __ ] dude that is
do you think adolf hitler was right for
killing 6 million jews why would you
give this to me
why would you give that to me
i'm jewish
[Laughter]
would you watch a 25-minute dirty sex
tape of your daughter for a million
dollars where am i at in my life
financially at the time do i need this
million
right now
and we and we did specify dirty because
it's not like it's just like uh she's
laying there and we're talking about
performance she's [ __ ] yeah
i can't man i i guess there's that
minute like i'm like make a joke out of
this and i'm like nah i'm not a complete
nutter pig i'm
five million
all right honey shake what your mama
gave you girl
it's five million dollars we're doing
pretty good we are doing pretty good
yeah dude
that was awesome all right big thanks
for watching ati featuring josh out of
myers leave a comment below who you want
next those are big shoes to fill but if
you know any comic or entertainer or or
celebrity that you think can follow up
josh's performance let us know make sure
you click subscribe so that you know
that anytime an ati video drops you're
there to see it